as a developer one of the things one of
the things we commonly you know as
security consultants trained development
teams for and in architects and other
folks involved in the creation of
software is threat modeling and that's
where we kind of just go through a
brainstorming exercise and we think of
all the threats that exist against what
we're trying to create and think about
how the application can be attacked how
can be compromised and if these attacks
are successful what's what does it mean
against the bottom line how much is it
going to cost us if certain attack
results in a breach or some sort of data
so that was about modeling and there's
also the concept of modeling out abuse
cases as well right not just a use case
right but individual any developers
don't think in terms of abuse cases
right what what would a malicious person
you know it was someone with malicious
intent do through the how would they
walk to the application how could they
potentially terminal itself right so a
use case might be we need to let the
user enter their credentials and store
them you know permanently or
semi-permanent evening an abuse case for
that would be well a third party
application exists on the device the
device is jailbroken and it you know
spiders the file system and finds this
file containing our users credential or
or an attacker trying to be used for
about password feature time to gain
exactly so let the point being we do the
threat modeling also notice like our
risk assessment we figure out okay what
is our true risk here then we can kind
of make a decision like okay maybe it's
okay to store these credentials it's
just for our gaming platform but when we
say okay this is an e-commerce site and
the credentials can be used to
potentially access credit card data for
our customer maybe it's not worth it for
us to store these credentials on the
devices so I really think it's important
that developers and other folks involved
in creating this software they really
think about what does the application
really need to do and what are the risks
inherent with that and then if they
decide that you know it's it's the risk
is acceptable to us you know we'd like
to store the credentials on the device
then they need to understand what secure
mechanisms exist on the platform that
will allow them to do that and this will
be platform specific forms a cynic
correct well if I'm a developer and I'm
trying to get used to this concept maybe
this concept of of creating abuse cases
is a little bit new to me how do i do I
get started writing an abuse case for my
app like I guess basically think like a
hacker yeah any other any other type
tricks or more tips in order to help
somebody think about how to come up with
malicious ways to circumvent off or do
the nasty things inside an application
yeah you know it really is you have to
put your bad guy hat on and just really
start to think outside of the box and
you know that could be pretty hard for
you to do just sitting at your desk by
yourself so it can be a fun exercise to
get the whole team involved and you can
potentially bring in a security guide to
just give a talk even just a little bit
more in-depth a 45-minute presentation
on threat modeling and giving up a mock
threat model will really kind of you
know open your open your eyes and get
you thinking and in a different way but
is what what you need to do if you want
to find these flaws be before they come
to exist in your